[Musique]
tout le monde a vu blade runner
alors on va ouvrir le micro d'emmanuel
carrère et on va l'écouter parler de
blade runner de ridley scott
oui mais c'est un film de science
fiction qui est il dans le sujet est
très beau le scénario est le problème
c'est que le scénario est détestable
film était le sujet et sur les ce qu'on
appelle dans le film les réplicants
c'est à dire des gens qui ne sont pas
des des créations enfin des artefacts
qui sont pas des êtres humains qui sont
censé ressembler à des êtres humains
mais le sujet du film c'est quand quand
le quand une imitation été parfait ce
que marcel dassault pour être un
réplique en sang mais un sens les faits
quand tu n'y penses pas peut-être le
problème c'est là quand une imitation
est absolument parfaite
on voit absolument plus ce qui la
distingue que d'année d'un être humain
véritable de l'original donc à quoi est
ce qu'on a
qu'est ce qui permet de voir c'est une
chronique des réplicants de l'em2
problème c'est pas tellement c'est que
le ce sujet superbe et très peu traité
et que bon c'est un c'est un film
visuellement magnifique c'est un film de
des noms bien sûr c'est beaucoup mais
c'est parler la poudre face et encore
heureux que ce soit beau c'est un film
d'effets spéciaux de décors splendides
et au début pendant une bonne demi-heure
c'est très séduisant et très excitant
parce qu'il ya vraiment une re
conseiller la reconstitution d'un monde
de futuriste qui est très convaincante
très où il ya une atmosphère asiatiques
et des des fast food chinois partout des
c'est très beau mais ensuite on
s'aperçoit qui a pratiquement pas de
scénario qui est un sujet super et est
une histoire qui te qu'ils laissent pas
souvent le cas de scott qui est un très
grand faisait également formellement
précédente assez mais pardon il s'est
ainsi beau film qui se passait dans le
passé qui était duellistes qui a été son
meilleur film
enfin ce qui me concerne cela dit depuis
s'est lancé dans alien il s'est lancé
dans blade runner lead runner j'ai un
petit peu de problèmes pour en parler
parce que je fais un rejet total de la
science fiction a c'est à dire que tout
ce qui va se passer au delà des
prochaines municipales mouassa médecin
me de complètement égal ce qui fait que
alors vous pensez que la californie en
2020 qu'est-ce que je m'en tamponne le
futurisme ça commence ce soir pour vous
dis oui
et il ya les androïdes les fameuses
android qu'on appelle des réplicants qui
ont l'air d'une assemblée de pompes pop
simon croiser balader à la bastille ou à
la république et qui sent bon donc des
répliques parfaites de l'être humain
mais il y avait une formidablement bonne
idée c'est qu'ils nous ressemblent ils
ont tous enfin quand je dis parfait je
veux dire qu'ils nous ressemblent à ceux
des romania qu'il soit parfait et mais
il y avait une formidablement venu et
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de souvenirs
d'enfance c'est par là qu'on les coins
ronds de la chance ils n'ont pas de
souvenirs d'enfance et c'est donc pas de
complexe d'oedipe rien c'est donc une
idée qu'on pouvait creuser or pas du
tout on vous dit simplement mais ils ont
pas de sourire d'enfant c'est comme ça
qu'on les coins sera bon alors une fois
que vous aurez dit qu'en effet le
monsieur qui a fait le décor s'est
surpassée c'est très très beau il ya
ralala ya des décors ya la nuit à la
mégalopole à la boue de vue que c'est
impressionnant et tout mais enfin ça
fait pas deux heures et alors il y à
quoi il y à violence gants serra tatham
on arrive au bout du film tout ça pour
avoir fait ses couleurs à la mode il ces
violences violences et était prévue à la
fin du film - répliquant hyper décolorés
plaque tirer tous mais face à la caméra
et dit je me demande d'où je viens où je
vais et pourquoi je suis là quelque
chose comme ça s'il aurait pu dire donc
dire où vais je cours en anglais et dans
quelle étagère way a failli il a fait il
l'a fait quand il faut donc 20 minutes
d'émission avant d'avoir 2 3 me et
calembours mais devant ça forestier vous
laisser poursuivre il ya d'accord pour
là si vous êtes pris la parole afin d'
accord ait pas d'accord c'est à dire que
je garais l'émission et pourtant charron
seul mais pas là quand je trouve que le
film est intéressant effectivement sur
le plan visuel c'est à dire que
il ya deux genres qui se mélange il ya
le film commence c'est une enquête qu'on
va voir dans le los angelès de 2019
on prend un détective privé qui va être
obligé de rattraper les cinq robots
répliquant appelez les comme 2010 après
jésus-christ après jésus christ et il
doit les abattre puisqu'il commence à
devenir dangereuse bien alors ce que
j'aime dans le film c'est le côté série
noire ça c'est formidable ce qu'il ya
effectivement une ambiance série noire
qui se passe dans l'avenir avec des
côtés salle il ya tout un côté si vous
voulez dans le décor on voit que les
choses ne sont pas neufs en voit que les
cabines téléphoniques qui ont des postes
de télévision qui sont formidables
comment on rêve dans l'avoir commence à
être couverte de graffitis les rues sont
pleines de boue il ya des voitures
garées un peu partout enfin il ya aussi
des gens qui circule en vélo moi j'aime
bien ce mélange comme ça visuellement
c'est assez beau le côté science fiction
même m'intéresse moins c'est à dire le
côté effectivement comme disait odile le
côté métaphysique de l'avenir qui
suivent dans quelle étagère et c'est ça
c'est moins intéressant mais c'est un
des péchés de la science-fiction tombe
toujours dans un côté balourd comme ça
est-ce que les est ce que les robots ont
une âme est ce qu'on peut t'on le type
tombe amoureux en plus d'une robe est ce
si j'ose dire
alors évident chez pas comment il va
enfin bon bref ils sont reçus
pudiquement sophie soumis d'enfance
voilà il ya effectivement des scènes
qu'ils ont très très belle par exemple
le type qui les a inventés les robots et
qui travaille dans un univers peuplé de
petits nains comme ça qu'ils sont tous
des robots qui s'habille comme napoléon
aquitain c'est très très beau c'est vrai
que le scénario souffre par moments
étant donné qu'il ya eu trois
producteurs sur le film et qui a eu à
harrison ford qui est la star du film et
que chacun des trois producteurs avaient
un avis différent et que harrison ford
lui-même avait un avis différent ce qui
fait qu'on a tourné deux fins pour le
film on en a utilisé l'une et par
l'autre qui fait qu'effectivement un
moment le le tout l'action ralentit
c'est un peu boiteux tout ça mais enfin
si vous aimez les très belles images si
vous voulez savoir à quoi ressemblera
les villes alors ressembleront les
villes dans lesquelles nous vivons
bientôt je pense que ça vaut le détour
voilà c'est donc que la vie de françois
forestier le répliquant de georges
charensol sais pas si j'ai me répandre
la défense de ces fameux robot bat
d'abord parce qu'ils sont incarnés par
des comédiens comme vous et moi je vous
assure que ce ne sont pas du tout des
machines
enfin comme moi pas comme les vrais
acteurs et en plus ces braves gens ont
une raison de tuer les hommes parce que
on vous a caché que pour qu'ils ne
nuisent pas à l'espèce humaine pour
qu'il y ait malgré tout une différence
non seulement ils n'ont pas de souvenirs
d'enfance mais on leur en a fabriqué ce
qui crée une ambiguïté
simplement on leur a donné une durée de
vie très courte et ce qu'ils viennent
faire sur terre c'est une sorte de grève
par la violence en réclamant un sursis
une vie beaucoup plus longue comme on ne
veut pas leur accorder à l'oreca sweet
tue les gens enfin forme à sa leçon mais
je les comprends
nous sommes en période de revendications
je ne vois pas pourquoi aussi il ne
n'aurais pas quand même
moi un petit supplément libérer cela ni
piquant cela dit c'est un type de cinéma
que je déteste parce que ils y achètent
des ridley scott et depuis aliens une
morbidité profonde sous jacente et même
évidente au premier degré qui devrait
créer le malaise chez tout spectateur et
- walt disney ce qui est mon cas
parce que tu es toujours pas aimer les
vices la lumière est profondément au
bloc et c'est vrai que ce que françois
forestier décrivez tout à l'heure c'est
à dire les décors qui sont assez
magnifique parce qu'ils sont patinées
encrassé parce qu'il pleut tout le temps
parce qu'il ya de la brume
mais tout ceci va dans le sens d'une
espèce de d'obscurité malsaine
métaphysique scott veut introduire dans
ses films et alien c'était pareil
souvenez-vous le vaisseau spatial
c'était le premier vaisseau spatial où
personne n'avait balayé dans les coins
c'était le vaisseau spatial le plus
dégueulasse qu'on n'ait jamais vu sur un
écran et c'est pas étonnant qu'il ait
une bête monstrueuse à l'intérieur alors
là il renchérit c'est à dire los angeles
est épouvantablement salle on n'est pas
monté dans un taxi même taxi volant et
les gens sont obligés de vivre là dedans
dit non non aux pyramides aztèques vous
ne seriez pas monter au nom pas d'accord
au sommet des postulats du film c'est
que les villes vont s'élever en hauteur
et qu'en dessous du 60e étage tout ce
qui est en dessous ce sera des hlm
dégueulasse sa salle il y aura des
voitures ils passeront devant des
voitures volantes et c'est ce que ça
sera très luxueux et comme les immeubles
font ch et 520 étage il y aura une
division en hauteur et je pense que
c'est assez plausible est qu'il faut
s'il est belle si tu as remarqué même au
sein 80e étage la pollution et glee
c'est à dire on ne voit rien
d'intéressant par les fenêtres un sacré
venir pour ati spliff la tisanerie
android prendre la parole du tpir
sainte-thérèse
cet univers que n'aime pas michel marder
et moi qui ne suis pas particulièrement
père partisans des films bien récurent
et je dois dire que j'adore me traynard
je trouve que c'est l'un des meilleurs
films qu'on ait vues depuis la rentrée
cet univers-là existe déjà il est en
gestation dans la los angelès actuelle
et ce qui est extraordinaire l'habileté
du décorateur l'habilité de l'homme des
effets spéciaux qui donne l'astroballe
ce par n'importe qui puis l'habileté
évidemment de ridley scott c'est d'avoir
pris tous les éléments de sa
construction futuriste dans la réalité
contemporaine
il imagine que los angelès on en 2019 ce
serait une sorte de site extraordinaire
où il y aura un mélange de races entre
les jeunes des asiatiques entre les
espagnols notre les américains du nord
qui dura même une langue nouvelle qui
sera un mélange de japonais des
américains des espagnols etc
il montre des gadgets qui sont déjà en
utilisation aux états unis mais il les
montre justement comme des vieilles
choses déjà usées etc
et je trouve que d'avoir créé cette
réalité future à partir d'éléments qui
existent déjà aujourd'hui c'est une
espèce de dons de visionnaire qu'il faut
pour le faire et je on a dit un peu
dédaigneusement oui c'est très très
belle très belle image décor superbe
spectacle extraordinaire on regarde ça
d'un peu haut mais je dis attention il
ya quelque chose de plus d'être les
grandes superproduction américaine
américaine actuellement non pas de
scénario ils ont des scénarios infantile
c'est vrai le film de ridley scott ne
fait pas exception à la règle
le scénario tout ce qu'on a dit au
dessus je suis d'accord c'est ça n'a pas
plus de consistance qu'un livret d'opéra
et encore il ya des livrets d'opéra qui
sont tellement bien l'agencé lesquels
ben je sais pas je pense à ce tout finit
par exemple ce type kaloum c'est pas mal
non plus d'accord bon mais cela dit
c'est vrai que le scénario de bad run
nord n'est pas formidable on pouvait en
tirer quelque chose de se développer on
pouvait approfondir mais on mais il ya
quand même il ya l'élément images
éléments image ce n'est pas seulement
une question de décors acteur ce n'est
pas seulement une question de d'effets
spéciaux et une question de mise en ce 1
et il y a le fait que ridley scott est
capable d'organiser du commencement à la
fin c'est univers extraordinaire ce los
angeles où il pleut tout le temps où
tous pourris lentement et univers de
désespoir extrêmement pittoresque en
même temps tout à fait morbide et
glauque comme d'audimat dans ça c'est
vrai
c'est vrai mais ça tient debout ça tient
debout on peut pas en dire autant de la
plupart des superproductions américaines
qu'on voit depuis quelques années parce
que ce sont des choses qui font de la
feuille de route etc
on en a plein la vue puis on se dit à
quoi bon tandis que là ça c'était un
univers qui restent qui vous colle à la
peau
dans le canon l'impression de marcher on
patauge avec les figurants qui sont là
dedans ça ça vous c'est une expérience
qui vaut la peine d'être vue d'être
vécue et même senti je dis papa je me
demande d'ailleurs si si le scénario
avait été plus consistants si on est on
serait plus sensible à cette fois ça y
est on en veut pour preuve que alien ou
le scénario était très consistants et
très mécanique
ce choix s'est fait sur le scénario
évidemment besoin mécanique il ya une
ambiance comme un bon c'est pas un grand
film mais il ya une ambiance à laquelle
on peut se laisser prendre ou pas ça
c'est bien difficile de passer ses
points bas de questions
[Musique]